What's up everybody!
I'm Emil from Pongfinity and today - as you
might see - we are doing some Christmas trick
shots!
Hope you enjoy!
First of all, Christmas is nothing without
a Christmas tree.
And a Christmas tree is nothing without some
decorations.
So, let's decorate the tree!
Let's start with some table tennis rubbers.
I have 10 rubbers here and let's see how many
will stay on the tree when I throw them.
Okay, that's pretty good!
Looks like I got 9 out of 10.
Now let's just finish off with some table
tennis balls.
Ok, so the Christmas tree is now decorated.
It looks pretty nice I think.
Let's take a closer look at it.
Next we need to light up the Christmas candles.
And to make this process a bit more interesting,
let's light the match with a table tennis
shot.
And then light the candles.
Ginger cookies are really good, but how many
of them is it possible to crush with 1 table
tennis shot?
I think the right answer is maybe 3, but let's
find that out now.
Okay this is creating such a mess on the floor
so it's better to stop here.
But apparently it's possible to hit even more
than 5, so maybe I'll try it out sometime
in the future.
You know, this Christmas elf looks like it
would like to play some table tennis.
So let's make that happen!
Always when you're lighting candles, you have
to remember to put them out.
So you can probably guess what I'm going to
do next.
But.
I'm going to do it with 2 consecutive shots.
Hope you guys enjoyed this video, it was a
lot of fun making it.
If you want to see more videos please leave
this video a thumbs up and if you are new
to the channel subscribe right here and watch
the previous episodes here.
Happy Holidays!